Lego thrives on versatility and variety
the brand has become associated with
everything from model towns to outer
space to licensed franchises like Star
Wars and original Ip like Bionicle and
Ninjago Lego 2K Drive is relatively
narrow compared to that wide array of
Lego iconography but that laser-like
Focus Works in its favor the team at 2K
and visual concepts has made a great
racing game first allowing the Lego
elements to organically add both an
astounding amount of customization and
flavorful visual flourishes to make a
lively and enjoyable open world Driving
Experience
under the hood Lego 2K Drive is a
combination of open world racing games
like Burnout Paradise or Forza Horizon
and card Racers like Mario Kart or Sonic
All-Stars the main campaign has you
exploring three big biomes each with
their own wide variety of activities and
events punctuated by cart races against
rival drivers who run these regions but
part of what makes both exploring and
racing so fun is how toy-like it feels
thanks to some smart systems that remove
any possible friction from exploration
when driving around in a typical open
World Racer you may have to set a
waypoint to your next objective and
spend a few minutes making your way over
by following the roads in Lego 2K drive
your vehicle Auto switches from Roadster
to off-road vehicle to boat based on
whatever you need at a given time a
generous Nitro boost and a dedicated
jump button meaning you can hop over
obstacles and scale mountains with ease
other cars are small buildings in the
way no problem just smash right through
them and they'll explode into a thousand
Lego bricks building your Boost meter in
the process this effectively makes the
whole world your playground letting you
carve a path right through it naturally
the races are more tightly controlled to
keep them competitive there are
checkpoints and hard walls but the races
add another layer that isn't present in
the open world in the form of power-ups
this is a staple of Kart Racers and the
ones present here are for the most part
fun and diverse ways to mess with your
opponents you can instantly tell the
rocket icon will let you fire a homing
missile at your next opponent for
example or the ghost icon makes you
invulnerable to obstacles for a short
time power-ups with less universally
recognized icons Like a Rolling mine
become clear enough after the first time
you use them the one major Miss among
the power-ups is the spiderweb which
falls into the Kart Racer weapon
category of obstructing your opponent's
View and slowing them down that effect
would be fine by itself but it also
forces you to jam on the button to clear
the web which just feels too distracting
and unfair in the middle of a race on
top of that the button is mapped to the
same one as jump so after clearing the
webs you're almost guaranteed to
accidentally jump when you didn't mean
to a late game race against a
spider-themed rival was especially
frustrating for this reason
the campaign's three biomes are bursting
with things to do in addition to
traditional kart races there are also
on-the-go events that trigger
automatically when you drive through a
gate many games like rescue in which you
help townspeople or defend where you
protect a set of towers then there are
World challenges to set record times and
quests where you'll help townspeople
with odd jobs
two of the three biomes big Butte County
and prospecto Valley can feel pretty
similar due to their sheer Cliffs and
Rural Landscapes but the third is a
radical departure both thematically and
Visually and sometimes your activities
can have permanent effects on the world
like mowing weeds down to replace them
with a speed boosting Crystal or
unlocking jet jumps that will populate
throughout the biomes
with a wide variety of vehicles that
have their own set of stats Lego 2K
drive also smartly lets you set a
handful of loadouts that can be swapped
anytime you're not actively in an event
one of your loadouts may be more focused
on maxing out your acceleration while
another could focus on hairpin turns as
you progress through the campaign you'll
also unlock the ability to equip
powerful perks which can have a huge
impact on your racing style and strategy
the presentation is perfectly kid
friendly but the racing hooks are deep
enough to draw in arcade racing fans of
any age
I did hit a pacing issue once when
nearing the end when I needed to grind a
few levels to qualify for the next phase
of the story I found that most of the
mini games and quests rewarded very
little XP so my best bet was to replay
races I had already accomplished on
harder or even easier difficulties it
was a small Road bump but notable since
it added an hour or so of extra play
time to what is easily an 8 to 10 hour
core campaign the length would have been
perfectly satisfying without the extra
padding the final race in the sky cup
Grand Prix is an especially thrilling
High Point pun intended and even after
finishing the campaign the open world
still feels inviting and fresh with tons
of challenges I haven't even touched yet
while not exactly affiliated with the
Lego Movie Lego 2K Drive obviously took
tonal cues from the hit animated film
the setting is mostly city-based sets
and the writing carries that same sense
of tongue-in-cheek all ages humor that
occasionally breaks the fourth wall the
interplay between the two race
announcers is a highlight with hilarious
commentary between major races your
ultimate goal is to gather enough Flags
to qualify for the sky cup Grand Prix
the ultimate racing competition held in
a floating Race Across the clouds which
is currently dominated by an obnoxious
cheater named Shadow Z
a veteran racer named clutch racington
sees potential in you and becomes your
clueless comic Mentor ushering you
through the steps of your journey to
become the ultimate driver and unseat
Shadow Z with that emphasis on plucking
your racer from obscurity to become a
new Champion you might expect there to
be heavy character customization but
sadly there isn't you can pick from a
handful of pre-made models but you can't
craft your own Lego minifig character
from scratch or even mix and match parts
from the models you have available
however more models unlock as you go
through the campaign and there are more
available to buy in the shop that's an
odd oversight given how remarkably
robust Lego 2K Drive is when it comes to
vehicle crafting the building interface
is incredibly flexible and evocative of
an actual Lego building set the menus
are so full featured that it can be a
little overwhelming at first but it
doesn't take too long to get a feel for
all of your options and start tinkering
away you can start a building from
scratch modify and exist existing model
with new parts or even give your
favorite car a custom paint job
ultimately the building options are
cosmetic and no amount of flaps will
make your car Airborne how it actually
handles comes down to the stats which is
its own Sub menu while the pre-built
Vehicles you obtain in the campaign will
have their own values assigned to Stats
like top speed and health in build mode
you can select from several stat
packages that balance your values with
names like Health option which gives you
high health or edging out which gives
you good top speed and maneuverability
at the expense of your health you can
purchase higher tier stat packs with
your earned cash but they're all
relatively inexpensive and the presets
keep any of them from feeling unbalanced
it's also nicely flexible in that there
doesn't seem to be a limit on which
stats you can attach to vehicles but I
had no problem attaching the same stat
package to both a light and very heavy
vehicle for a more meditative experience
the build shop also includes and
instructions mode made to imitate the
feeling of actually building a Lego set
from a bag of full Parts it breaks down
one of the pre-built models giving you
individual steps with several parts to
assemble and then you simply grab them
one at a time to rotate and then click
them into place expanding on your
collection of cars to have more to build
and modify is where Lego 2K Drive
appears to aim to have longevity a
season pass called the drive pass
promises more Racers and vehicles but it
isn't active at the time of this review
aside from a wide array of vehicles
you'll also earn money through the
campaign but having completed it I have
barely enough to buy a few cars so it
seems clear that the goal is to keep
players coming back long term you can
also buy premium currency and then turn
it into in-game currency which can
certainly be a concern for a
kid-friendly game with slow in-game
progression but since any competitive
Advantage comes from an inexpensive stat
pack themselves there doesn't seem to be
a competitive advantage for the DLC
Vehicles whatever the future holds Lego
2K drive is already a complete package a
raucous arcade racer that marries
elements of open World Racing and kart
racing and wraps it all in a bright
playful Lego package it has enough Real
Racing bonifies to satisfy adults but
the most pleasant surprise is how its
combination of humor explosive action
and robust building tools will make you
feel like a kid again
[Music]
thank you